des mois qu'il n'avait plus quitté la
maison d'arrêt de dijon où il est
incarcéré depuis janvier 2018
johnatan d'aval a été transféré très tôt
ce matin au palais de justice de vesoul
la première image d'une semaine hors
norme celle d'un procès au
retentissement national en veut aux
houles n'a jamais connu un tel un tel
événement triste
naturellement on s'en serait bien passé
mais on espère que tout se passera bien
la logistique a été organisée comme tel
au ballet médiatique a vite succédé
celui des avocats avant l'arrivée très
attendue de la famille d'alexia d'aval
un moment chargé en émotion pour ces
parents isabelle et jean pierre foule on
sait qu'on va être très bien défendu
qu'alexi avais tu sais le procès de
johnatan et je ne veux pas que ce soit
le procès d'alexiane les gens qui aiment
cette famille ont subi aussi la perte
d'alexia ont suivi la trahison et ont
suivi même la douleur de la famille
d'alexia parce que tout ça a été très
très très lourd très pénible que s'est
il réellement passé au cours de cette
nuit du 27 au 28 octobre 2010 est celle
qui a précédé la mort d'alexia malgré
les aveux de l'accusé les zones d'ombré
restent nombreuses la première question
était de savoir pourquoi lui qu'on
aimait tant
on peut dire que c'était de deux virus
liste de la famille pourquoi j'ai fait
ça et pourquoi surtout après at il
adopté une stratégie de défense aussi
une grotesque capj actes c'est à ces
questions là qu'on attend des réponses
dans le box des accusés johnatan d'aval
pourra lui aussi compter sur le soutien
de ses proches sa mère martine henry
était bien présente ce matin à
l'ouverture de l'audience
et comment vous avez trouvé votre fils
bien j'ai trouvé
ouais
il sera accusé de meurtre sur conjoint
johnattan d'aval risque la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
pour l'instant ses avocats n'ont pas
souhaité s'exprimer mais devrait le
faire dans la soirée pas pour l'instant
tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure